watching your ass jiggle on that table
will permanently scar me but otherwise
I'm amazing
four [ __ ]
[Music]
Kristen are you aware of this whole Adam
Levine thing that's going around uh with
his wife yeah a little bit oh dude I've
seen some memes I always read all of me
he's like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] your body's
absurd yeah
is that a compliment but I actually
don't like fully know the story so you
want to educate me yeah I mean it's it's
pretty much exactly what he just did
did a cam girl screenshot him saying
that well and that became a thing ton of
checks coming out oh really it was it
wasn't just one no there's like over
five there's more but the main one is
the one you're thinking about her name's
Sumner stroll and he was Summoner strong
I know it sounds like I have a stutter
but it's really her name she was uh
corresponding with him via DMS in which
you know he was kind of complimenting
her very Tastefully as you just
demonstrated and then what happened is
she didn't screenshot it and send it out
to the world or anything she said she
sent that screenshot to her like
girlfriends or whatever and then one of
them like it got around and one of them
was uh gonna sell it what but then it
got out anyway well I don't know if she
put it out to stop her friend from
selling from tablets [ __ ] put it out
there herself hey big moves Christian
can you answer why girls can't keep a
secret no matter what
because that's the root of the issue
yeah I don't know
[Laughter]
he's all like it's just a it's in our
DNA bro you want to tell me a secret
every everybody's kind of uh the main
thing is the not so much that he he was
married and was texting or like dming
other girls stuff like that the main
factor of the thing is how cringy his
flirting is and that's what he's getting
like roasted about because you would
think someone at that level who have
like girls just tripping in lines over
him that he would be way smoother than
that yeah he's got no ribs like
absolutely no reason
can you read this and then try to sell
this in the most sexiest way you can the
smoothest most player way you could do
it Joe look at me while you're saying
yeah try it on Kristen oh this is the
[ __ ] how am I gonna work with this
okay
it is truly unreal how [ __ ] hot you
are that's that's the no more part like
it blows my mind
it blows my mind I can't even read this
with us
this is corny bro like who talks like
this unreal it's unreal it's truly
unreal how [ __ ] hot you are he sounds
like a Junior High girl in 2003 like it
literally like I'm surprised he doesn't
have literally in here like it blows my
mind like it blows my mind it sounds
like he's never talked to a girl in his
life you know what you know what it
might also be oh he said like it blows
my mind um
that was a Maroon 5 original
so uh it might also be due to the fact
that some guys that don't need to try as
hard for other reasons like success or
looks they tend to kind of lack in that
department oh they don't have the
practice
it just comes to them so easily digging
ourselves up from the ditches off camera
we've spoken to a couple of our
um popular female friends
who get courted by Mega celebrities
right and they've told us that a lot of
them don't have game
and and it's because they don't have to
work they don't need it sometimes they
don't even make a message like they'll
just leave a like a like a space like a
DM yo and it's like a period or like an
empty and then you'll get that in a DM
because then girls like oh my God
whatever but they're fishing right and
then if they if a girl doesn't respond
they take that away
like because you know you could delete
the thing and then it's like it never
happened okay because they also have to
probably cover their tracks some of the
dime piece homies will just be like if
I'm at if I'm at the bar like
at least one chick will come and talk to
me I'm like damn I wonder what that
feels like dude we have a dime piece
homie that I was I was taking place
that's [ __ ] crazy a dime piece like a
10 out of 10.
I'm dying but it's usually dying die in
peace it's usually a dress towards women
like dime pieces that's how you know the
Gen Z and Millennial just split right
now
it's okay so so we know someone I was at
the uh club with them in NorCal and
we're just hanging out
this girl comes up to him and then
um I was like what is she saying she
goes oh she was just like yeah I'm just
here for the weekend you know me and my
friends just
just with my friends you know like that
kind of [ __ ] and I was like wait what
and then like she came back around again
and then so he didn't get the point she
was just like take me to your room oh
and then I was just like listening like
oh my God and and our buddies are very
he's a loyal sweetheart he's even loyal
to the person that he's not even with oh
got it yeah he's loyal to his interest
yeah yeah yeah yeah so like so like I
was like wow
that's what it's like to be
a male model oh yeah yeah you don't have
to work yeah yeah I understand credible
you just have to figure it out when we
were on uh when we were doing
International tour like with Quest Crew
uh we got one guy his name's Brian
harano and he's just like the most out
of all of us he's like just so
objectively hot buff nice chest he's
Hoppa so he's like every [ __ ] girl's
dream in that way and uh don't be
jealous of my kids they're gonna be hot
yeah and when we would be in like these
different countries at these After
parties kind of chatting up with girls
trying to build rapport I kid you not
I'm putting them out here like really
bad but with no words he would just look
at a girl once he gets that eye contact
he just puts his hand out and then they
just go oh my God why and then they just
go bye-bye and that's it no words really
yeah we were like dude you're the silent
King and and it works everywhere because
we don't speak the language and majority
does it work on guys too
like guys are just like oh [ __ ] what the
[Laughter]
yeah it's like I'm not gay but I gotta
do this man
but then you know it's like that's also
how some of us will view ourselves that
we need to kind of make this like
personality the Forefront a lot of time
because you know like myself I've always
thought I'm a niche person like if
you're just not into my type you
probably there's nothing I could say to
convince you kind of a deal but then
someone like gives you has a confidence
of like oh I know like what check marks
are in one I'm a universal remote
exactly work on everything so this is
all you need to do is extend the Olive
Branch the Olive Branch would something
like this work on you in any way yeah
absolutely not no matter who said you if
anyone said that who's your like top
who's your top celebrity crush of all
time
so we can put it into perspective
Tom Holland Tom Holland no I I really
it's more so for the character but I
love Tony Stark like Iron Man what if
Tony Stark like some like little
schmoozie Stark did that yeah not even
basically Iron Man himself
Jarvis take me but he brings out like
with his his Iron Man suit he extends
his hands a wedding ring comes in he's
like you are so hot
unbelievable literally no see that that
one it blows my armor
like it's really bad okay so what if he
uh offered to name his unborn child
after you
oh yeah because that's what he did too
oh he did that so he asked Sumner
he told her he wanted to name his baby
after her but that baby is with his oh
yeah but the other person that's a
[ __ ] weird in the message she was
like I'm dead serious he said dead
seriously in all caps it almost seems
like it's a joke maybe it's really good
promo for his next song
well happy Genie do you think at this
point he's just so used to getting women
without even trying that he's just
playing anyway to make it fun and saying
this most ridiculous thing maybe that
could be relatable is he he hasn't
spoken about it how what's going on with
the wife like what's up who who's worse
him or R Kelly
question is that
um
early R Kelly he's freaky right so he's
doing really freaky [ __ ] yeah I don't
know what the [ __ ] this guy's doing can
you do this one now it just starts here
and that's his
all right you gotta include all the
caves with the sexy voice
seriously [ __ ]
and in a photo shown any hearts the
photo
I made it I may need to need to see the
booty
[ __ ] and it says no booty
I may need to see the booty
wait is this is this the girl that he
did that to no that's the girl that's
like commentary oh okay okay yeah
I may need to see the booty as I make
you feel
hot and bothered so uncomfortable yeah
right
dude she's feeling it man
I'm so sorry no it's all right what's
happening it's the music video like to
one of his songs and like picturing him
like [ __ ] okay he's like your body's
unbelievable I know it's like someone
else is riding for you then yeah it
doesn't like match
that's how I brought up R Kelly because
I was like this ruined their music for
me
oh R Kelly no no this guy but not R
Kelly R Kelly I don't know it's separate
so you're giving R Kelly a passport so R
Kelly he has those [ __ ] wedding
anthems right like Step In The Name of
Love like that stuff I will forever love
I'll forever love that music this I
don't think I could listen to Maroon 5
or Adam Levine ever again because I'm
gonna think about this weird ass [ __ ]
you know what because because this
violates who I thought he was I know he
seems like a really dope guy yeah and
then because R Kelly I knew he was crazy
yeah it's like and I knew he was pissing
on girls yeah wait he was pissing on
girls yeah the Peace Day resistance this
would be the final one just go ahead and
go down there I have not seen this one
yes watching your ass jiggle on that
table will permanently scar me but
otherwise I'm amazing
[Laughter]
I'd buy it a steak dinner and whisper
sweet nothings to it I want to tattoo my
ass now Nate may come to Maui and tattoo
me and surf I need to put some clouds
behind the reaper what does that even
mean all right there's something missing
that might just be a real conversation
though or maybe he's talking about his
tattoo maybe he has a Reaper he wants to
put cloud Who's name or maybe he's like
writing lyrics and like sending it to
her I think he starts talking about some
other [ __ ] but yeah I guess he likes
going to Maui and surfing that's weird
yeah the funniest one that I saw is uh
him at a feminist March and he's wearing
a t-shirt that says feminist yeah except
he's cheating on his wife the whole time
okay that's that's kind of the main yeah
that's the main thing do we see this as
cheating
has he has he has he hooked up with any
of these people or like a legend no he
said he's denying any kind of action
well he just flirts a lot it's just
flirting I I guess it's female
empowerment through the DMS right it's
what female empowerment through the DMS
he is in line with his feminism true
he's lifting up yeah maybe okay everyone
yeah just being nice yeah so that's not
cheating you don't think no so I'm gonna
DM him right now
[Music]
thank you
foreign